good morning guys we're having your
nacho average february that's for sure
welcome jerry well done
we're shaking around a little bit this
morning nice sunshine clear skies you
can see the camera's shaking we've got
some northerly breezes out there we've
got ash and juniper blooming and on the
bubble of high counts now overall
moderate but sometimes tipping over and
so if you're sneezing you better take
your antihistamines chances are you're
allergic to either of those junipers
cedar bushes cedar trees but we have a
lot of ash trees planted in southern
nevada they give great shade so a lot of
the neighborhoods over the last 20 years
or so have ash trees because they do
provide nice shade but boy they sure do
bloom and make a lot of people sneeze so
we've got a lot of 50s around the valley
north valley has had more wind than
pretty much the rest of the
neighborhoods in the valley but along
the colorado river valley it's been
quite windy especially back at midnight
winds have backed off a little bit but
the weather service actually issued a
wind advisory there i'll show you in
just a second 74 is what we're looking
for sun is up now 6 33 the sunrise 62 is
the average high records are in the
upper 70s and we'll be a lot closer to
those records as we get through the rest
of the week and into the weekend again
hot and windy southern california
dealing with wildfire situation now a
big brush fire that's spreading near
laguna beach they've got evacuations
going on right now all along the pch
pacific coast highway it's been very
scary 40 plus mile an hour wind
spreading those flames through the
hillsides and back here at home we'll
talk more about that wind advisory until
four o'clock it's all along the colorado
river valley lake mojave and out to lake
mead until four o'clock could see some
40 mile an hour winds so for the valley
15 20 mile an hour winds in isolated
areas 74 is what we're looking for today
if you're going out to the lake just
know there's going to be some choppy
waters with that wind advisory in place
the mountains 25 30 mile an hour winds
will keep the warmth all the way through
valentine's day monday and then a big
dramatic pattern change with a drop in
temperatures gusty winds and maybe even
a slight chance of some showers around
tuesday maybe some mountain snow and 60s
back next week